hi there Steve here continuing with my
Korean challenge today I want to talk
about randomness randomness in life
randomness in language learning yes
that's my wife playing the piano in the
background you know I've often felt that
one and one doesn't equal to what I mean
is that we cannot always anticipate
what's going to happen plan for what's
going to happen because very often what
happens is what we least planned for and
I'm going to talk about initially but my
own life and related back the language
learning as i always try to do so today
i went to a cooking class and at the end
of the video you'll see some pictures it
was a 90-minute cooking class no three
hour cooking class first time I've ever
done anything like that the only reason
I did it is because I started in the
cooking and the only only reason I
started in the cooking is because my
wife had a bunion operation and was
emobile and therefore someone she
couldn't stand her she had to have her
leg up all the time and i love it now
i'm just having a ball with my cookie so
that's the first thing so i wouldn't
have started into it if my wife hadn't
had a bunion operation so you never know
what's gonna lead to what and I'm really
enjoying it I can't get enough of it I
cooked again tonight I had a blast
that's number one number two while I
cook not all the time but a lot of time
I'm listening so I usually listen to
korean but i decided today to listen to
some russian and i must say that i like
say benedict off at Acoma squeak who I
often disagree with and I'm not quite
sure what his role is how he manages to
keep his skin running a radio station
that's owned by Gazprom which is
essentially a government-owned you know
natural gas producing company and yet he
has a lot of people on there who are
very critical of the government and he
himself skates a delicate line but he's
very often critical but he had a very
good
and he took over from setting a pot home
Inca who was one of my favorite guys in
e-commerce Pete and who has his suits
abhijit and I like seven nicked off he
spoke about in absence of transponders
on russian military aircraft over the
Baltic the possible consequences of that
he stopped I spoke about this Minister
of Culture burden medinsky and problems
relating to his lack of genuine college
academic background and a whole bunch of
other stuff and he just spoke so very
well and he spoke in Russian and I
enjoyed it I don't have to agree with
everything that everybody says but he
uses the language well and it was it was
very very enjoyable I couldn't be I
couldn't be able to enjoy that if I
hadn't learned Russian and when it comes
to Korean now last couple of days there
have been these discussions at my
political podcast about this k sports
what do you call it you know foundation
and the mirror foundation which are
these some kind of a supposedly
charitable foundations that have been
misused and there's and I never couldn't
quite figure out what they were talking
about but I finally realized that this
is a major scandal in Korea this could
actually bring down the government so I
have been sort of listening in on these
discussions and gradually the picture is
becoming clearer and clearer and it's
just fun it's just fun to do that and
I'm doing it in Korean so I'm following
events in Korea that are of interest and
I find it interesting to follow
political events because we're all
impacted by them we have very little
influence beyond our vote and in the
case of say the u.s. presidential
election I have no vote down there but i
know i'll be very much impacted by
whatever happens and of course there
again we have the latest you know
excitement over this latest statement by
the FBI and i don't know where that's
all going to end up but for people who
are studying English and who are
interested in politics of course there's
just an abundance of material whereby
they can follow the events in the US
just as I follow
in Russia or events in Ukraine or events
in Korea and in doing so of course we
improve our language skills and for that
matter if you are not a native speaker
of English and if you have attended my
cooking class you would have learned a
lot about cooking you would have learned
English terms you would have had a
chance to meet the other 15 people or
maybe even more who participated and I
think that's often you know if I were to
go to Poland let's say to work on my
polish I would rather go to this the
local polish cooking class rather than
go to a Polish language school because
one on one one plus one doesn't always
equal to so there you have it on
randomness in general and randomness as
it affects language learning life now
you